you
I go in this cherry this is a round
eight game from the 2017 Tata Steel
chess tournament between Richard wrapper
playing on the white end the 20 year old
from Hungary one of the most original
players out there the top level he is
paired against our current world
champion Magnus Carlsen let's see what
we got 9f 3d 5d three any d3 fans out
there this is not so common at the top
level why well you're not going to get
any opening advantage playing b3 white
knows this white is looking for
something non theoretical black is fine
without both players I think are happy
with the opening results we do have a
playable position a very even ish
position for some time let's see what
follows Bishop f5 now when we have b3 as
a start how might you categorize this
well how do I categorize it I view this
as a non-confrontational start to chess
game there's no direct punches being
thrown let's say in the center no pawn
tension and the center just yet no
attack defense that sort of stuff
regarding the pawns in the center so
with Bishop f5 black is saying okay I'm
going to deploy my bad bishop outside of
the pawn chain this is super solid
so continuing we have e3 h6 to preserve
the bishop from any knight attack you
can always fly away Knight d2
Knight f6 okay just a nibble of tension
in the center on d5 that's offset C pawn
attacks d5 then we have the C pawn
defending d5
g3 Bishop to e7 so White's going for a
double theme kiddo
very solid structures for both sides if
you're curious about the decision with
the dark square bishop what are his
other options B 4 C 5 D 6 why not to any
of these let's just rule them out before
he gets kicked C 5 he's more accessible
potentially being kicked with a 3 B 4
can also have you know 2 C file open up
and the bishop can be struck out he's a
bit more accessible on c5 and the last
square why not let's say d6 well maybe
many of you can relate to this potential
for efore and then 5 and all of a sudden
you're in a fork so in order to steer
clear of that Bishop e7 at the end of
the day is best bit more modest looking
but stays out of trouble Bishop g2 both
sides capsule and both sides are playing
a bit of a mimicking game with the
Knights
okay white says I want a little bit of
space on the queenside King can we get a
little bit of space black says no I will
stop your idea to play d4 and now Queen
to be one so really this is where the
game begins an interesting thing for me
to share here is that I've played this
position I think multiple times for both
sides not in any serious games but blitz
games this is the type of position we
have here it's just ultra solid if we
strip this board of all pieces and just
look at the pawn structure it's it's a
just a perfect pawn structure for both
sides no no great gaps no exploitable
holes within one another's camp
let's see how play develops where will
there be you know now I deduce some
attention to the pawn structure where
will it change at what point will there
be let's say some target created in the
game after queen bee one we have now
Bishop to h7 this for me was always a
bit of a you know where do you go with
the bishop I've played this position
I've played Bishop to g6 and I've played
the bishop to h7 does it really matter
it's tough to really weigh which Square
is best
I've played both in the game it's Bishop
h7 I just like to touch on a couple
differences between the two squares if
you go to g6 you are potentially running
into a 95 move with an attack and I
think that that is the main reason why
black went all the way back the computer
is I mean if you throw it up against the
computer it'll kind of weigh both
squares with the bishop is you know
about the same so if you go to g6 you're
more vulnerable to an IED attack an 870
don't get that there's a downside with
Bishop h7 is that you take away the
flight square for your King I can play a
role in some stage and I've had that
happen to me so that's why I'm able to
be confident with sharing this
information with you
now why is the mission moving in the
first place well he's just a pre-emptive
move against some quick efore strike so
you have the time to do this to kind of
tuck in your pieces and make this let's
say prophylactic type of move and that's
what we get with move 11 Bishop h7 it is
something also worth noting here is that
that light square bishop blacks light
square bishop I've had this happen to me
a light square bishop can sometimes be
out of play if now I was saying it it
was backing up anticipating efore that's
not to say e4 is going to happen because
what I can do in this structure is
maintained d3 and e2 this just this just
these two pawns right here control the
bishop if they go unmoved the bishop is
forever let's say biting on a rock and
he is a king side specific piece it's
not really having a great influence on
the Queen side aside from just staring
at this one squared B 3 which is well
supported he's not really doing too much
now if ever efore he is then brought to
life his presence will be felt play
continues with b4
budging with these two puns b4 on board
is white losing a pawn no a takes a
takes and if Bishop takes on that would
be bad because of Bishop takes up six
winning a piece so this pawn is poison
Carlsen replies with Queen to b6
striking striking at this pawn now for a
second time so how to defend this Bishop
c3 defended twice but this Queen is
overloaded and now distracted deflected
rook takes or a queen takes rook to
attacker is only one defender on d4
Bishop takes Bishop takes Queen takes
blacks up upon but white is on move and
now hits the Queen and then gets the
pawn back so eighteen moves in and we're
just about I think maybe like a dozen
moves away from the end of this game
already we have a really active rook a
bishop on h7 that is not yet playing
so what should black do here well this
is the next thing is very important
black and needs to change the structure
as it stands right now with a couple
queenside tones wiped off the board a B
bonds they're gone
all the other puns if we have a look at
them where are the targets where is
there a target within the white pawn
structure where is a target within the
black pawn structure for black the only
weakness is c6 and that can be targeted
Queen a4 Queen a6 in some way maybe the
rook can also attack c6 it's not long
off before white starts to put pressure
on c6 where is the target within White's
camp if there is a soft point in White's
camp it would be e to the base point
both e2 and c6 or base points for each
side however when you look a bit more to
get a bit more technical about these two
vulnerable points for each side which
one is more accessible the c6 pawn is
more accessible than the e2 pump that's
how easily can't really put pressure on
e to quite easy to see how white you can
put pressure on c6 but not so much the
e2 pond so because of this what's
important is that black try and change
the structure well black is doing with
his next move 'if I've is looking to
play E for or you know yeah II for and
make a capture and have white recapture
and then all of a sudden that Bishop on
h7 the one who was biting on Iraq all
the sudden is brought to life if we have
the e pawns exchanged that Bishop is a
monster on h7 striking right at the
heart right at the base of White's pawn
structure so this is what black goes for
looking to change the structure looking
to create a more accessible target in
White's camp II five it is d4 is the
reply preparing
efore with 95 black captures and this is
I guess the main point in the game for
Team white spent about 22 minutes on
this move capturing on d4 you could take
with the Queen but I believe White's saw
this best as an opportunity to uncover
unmask the fiend cut out Bishop Knight
d4 the bishop is now contributing the
night is getting kicked with c5 and now
Knight to b3 not going back here he is
a little bit off to the side on b3 but
he is serving a pretty good role he is
now putting pressure on c5 I'd have some
coordination here the Knights are still
connected so to our blacks if there's
one key difference I'm really seeing in
this position type when you do a piece
comparison that white Brook on b7 is
fully mobilized he's not just on an open
file he's on the seventh ranked rook on
f8 his counterpart let's say yeah he's
not yet playing
just play follow we have d4 bishop h3
keying in on the d7 night d3 this is not
considered best one of the other
suggestions by the computer well an
alternative is route to b8 trying to
eliminate this active rook something
like this is called for so what the
computer likes well Carlsen tries
however is d3 pretty much saying give me
a pass pawn or activate my Bishop if you
take the pawn well this is now maybe one
of the best pieces that black has a
bishop deep in White's position hitting
at a lot of squares striking at C for
keeping pressure on one of the Queen
side pawns this is where there are
targets you see because there are still
a couple pawns on the Queen side this
has an influence on the quality of the
pieces which ones are all right we'll
have to defend the ponds which ones are
restricted which pieces are restricted
because there are Queen side ponds that
has an influence on again the quality of
these minor pieces and major pieces we
don't have the capture on d3 in this
game light instead looks to still to a
certain degree work against this light
square bishop now with that put this III
move black has this passed pawn but it's
tough to get rolling it's not the I mean
the knight is one of the best block
haters are they postponed
I don't know how happy and Knight is
block hating a passed pawn that is just
two squares away I think he still is
best but yeah a bit of a scary pawn on
d3 see if black can try and push this
pawn through what follows is 95 pressure
on c4 eyeing up now a gap in White's
position f3 that is a hole on f3 and
well this Bishop is now staring off into
space so he returns to the main diagonal
covers f3 it may be even eyes up a pivot
square on d5 Russy 8 and this is an
issue playing rook to ca in this
position actually I mean the decision to
play d4 was where there was a shift in
the evaluation computers suggesting the
knight simply returned to d7 pretty hard
move to make after you've just played
the e5 and your opponent goes here to go
back like this
but yeah rook c8 is played and now we
have f4 I didn't mention this yet but
when III is played like this and we have
move I exceed me when d3 is played and
then we have III that change in the
structure well what we have on the King
side now we have a four versus three a
couple moves later what do we now have
white is pushing the majority setting
that majority into motion not all the
pawns
when you have this four versus three it
is you know you don't just launch all
four pawns but rather you'll see the E
and F pawns really look to expand and
that's what we have here out of nowhere
that F pawn is now pressed forward with
the threat Knight g4 efore another
threat threatening a
and believe it or not black is already
in some serious hot water how do you
deal with 'if I've thrown a punch at the
Queen the night something I was touching
on earlier when I was saying where
exactly do you go with the bishop yeah
this ePHI move is now looking to hit at
the Queen and Knight
now the best move in the computer's eyes
is the moon I was played in the game
rook to e8 preparing to do what and give
up a night for two pawns and that's what
we have now let me just look at
something that's maybe more I don't know
more human-like to just you know at
least sidestep this fork idea suppose
Queen e6 what would happen on Queen e6
computer now suggest Queen a7 striking
at c5 and after Knight to e3 there's
rook to e7 look at these white pieces
the Queen in the rook and at some stage
there can even be a five Bishop to d5
this is already a big big problem for
team black this pawn is under control
this night is really deep in White's
position
but there's no other piece around to you
know help out there isn't a black queen
in this area of the board to try and
connect with the knight in any way
there isn't any great coordination so
you know Queen to a7 would be a strong
reply here and black will have a lot of
defensive responsibilities f7 once both
pieces are on the seventh rank so black
says that pressure would be too much I
am prepared to give up a night and get
two pawns and now look at the e2 square
maybe strike at the night maybe even get
down to the first rank trying to splodge
this night end I am just two squares
away from cleaning here maybe can chase
this night away let's see what happens
rook b6 Queen to e7 threatening to win
the Queen capturing the rook like this
there would follow Queen takes rook and
let's say Bishop g6 so that the King now
has that flight square there would be
Queen takes e5 white is up a full piece
here well okay black has a pawn but
where is the activity there isn't any
this is pretty much as far as I want to
take it after Bishop f1 this is a super
solid position for white essentialized
Queen she could not be dislodged she's
covering a ton of dark squares all the
key dark squares this pawn is now ready
to roll his passed pawn he can't even
move
he's blockaded and let's say if black
tries to get another night in or not
another night but a knight involved with
Knight g4 now he's now covered with h5
there's no threat even being thrown away
these squares again are all covered
white could continue to push short story
here is Queen takes rook is met with
Queen takes rook and white has no issues
the C c5 pawn will fall white will
centralize the Queen and there's no big
progress no good way forward for black
to even stir up any trouble because
white would have excellent coordination
so what is tried is Queen c7 looking to
pick up the Queen the fork
what follows is rook b8 have to block
with the knight of course and what would
we do as team light here what would you
do is team like if you'd like to go
ahead pause the video how would you deal
with the threat rook e1 picking up the
Queen what move would you play what move
did Richard play for move thirty-one
okay well
white ignored the threat rook e1 and
played Bishop c6 what in the world is
that
allows the queen to be picked up rookie
one White has seen this one through to
the end though Queen takes rook Queen
takes Queen and now simply Knight f1
locking the check and with that move
black resigns why well there is the
threat to not only give the knight or
should we take the knight and land a
fork but also there's a mate throw
involved
lack will be losing the Queen back very
soon
what do you do here Bishop g6 group
takes Knight Queen takes rook Bishop
takes Queen yeah white is up two minor
pieces there's nothing to do here
if you move the Queen wherever it's just
a million one white is starting to win
the queen or the king with rook takes
Knight this is a very powerful idea here
for white so there's nothing good left
for black to do but resign a very slow
start as we saw in this one you'll
notice that Bishop on h7 is it better to
have the bishop on g6 if the bishop was
on g6 instead of h7 this little tactic
of course you couldn't foresee this sort
of thing but this is the you know that
earlier decision do you go to g6 to go
to h7 is it better to have your Bishop
let's say vulnerable to a knight attack
being on g6 or are you okay with you
know you know having that slight square
taken away from your King because this
type of tactic doesn't work if the
bishop is on g6
anyhow some interesting points I think
at least to take away from this game
regarding the structure it started out
slow black needed to change the
structure in some way to create some
target we did get to see that had a d4
move that turned out to be not such a
good plan and white as we saw was able
to capitalize on that little mistake by
team black and just kind of snowballed
from there
anyhow feel free as usual to leave any
feedback to this video in the comment
section below and as always I hope you
got something out of it that's all for
now
take care
you
[Music]